Robert you mentioned previously that you
would not have embarked on kids for cash
if you could not tell the victims story
as well as the so-called villains story
so can you recount to us what it was
like the day you actually spoke to judge
Ciavarella and I mean where were you
what was it like when you approached him
to be in this film well I think to start
we really weren't gonna make the movie
unless we could tell from the Vilna
victims point of view because they think
that's like the classic story you know
and and almost from the beginning it
seemed like a tale right out of the
Charles Dickens book you know and and
and so the idea was to see if we could
approach him in fact my producing
partner and I thought there's no way
we're gonna get these judges to talk why
would they they're they're about to
undertake a federal prosecution why
would they do it but I didn't know them
but I knew of them and I was able to get
a meeting with one of the judges judge
Ciavarella and it was my pitch was
simple I said listen this is a
one-dimensional story in the media you
just maybe perhaps all your life we're
scheming to you know to for this to
happen you know to raise all this to put
kids away for for money and and I don't
think it happened that way but if there
must be another side to this whole story
and and judge says well of course
there's always a side but nobody wants
to hear it like well I'm interested in
hearing it but we're both but if you
agree to to work with us we're gonna
tell the story from both perspectives
and go wherever it goes and neither
judge knew that they were being filmed
neither judge by agreement knew that
they were being filmed but I can't be
sure that they didn't talk among
themselves I I'm not sure well they were
friends in the very beginning and they
were enemies at the end it's hard to
know in between if they had talked to
each other I don't know right so where
was the first meeting with judge
Ciavarella where did it take place
first meeting was in his daughter's home
because at this point judge sera had you
know sold his home so he's living with
his daughter so the first name a meeting
was there and you know cuz he was kind
of holed up there I mean he didn't go
out because when he went out
would mob oh wow so it was that he was
that well known even by fellow oh yeah
yeah I mean we had to sneak our
equipment into the into the condo that
he was living in because you know people
would see like what are they doing plus
the fact that we didn't want anyone to
find out that he was being interviewed
no one and and he said in particular the
other judge did too that he didn't want
his lawyer to know either and so it's
not kind of a burden we had to make sure
that we brought our crews in from New
York and you know big crew to a lot of
equipment how do we go how we gonna kill
this into your place but we had to do it
so that you know neighbors and others
didn't know what we're doing and how did
you do that just putting stuff in bags
yeah just making you know like small
like going in with you know and look to
having lookouts really just see like
make sure people didn't know that we
were around and just take stuff in
pieces at a time show up in multiple
vehicles park different places you know
so that we didn't have a big crew of
people walking into the place and
somehow we did it it's just amazing to
me to that that no one know that we were
we were filming them and how many
meetings did you have with him we had
you know maybe seven or eight interviews
over the course of years with with the
judges in different places you went all
in the same spot
you